this is a production of cornell
university
all right listen we got a lot to do in
30 minutes and it's so nice to have
everybody back whether you're watching
this live
and and ready to think about the
questions you want to ask or
or uh i think carl we're also going to
take questions we can start out next
week with
questions as well but i i want to get
right to it um
uh art and i and a lot of people have
been chatting for 20 some odd years in
the morning and we're
started this thing last year uh during
the pandemic when
you know it was a scary time for
everybody we just i felt like
i think i was so anxious i felt like i
needed to do something to feel like i
was contributing
and uh carl and i and listen i it's not
i it's carl and i and everybody on the
team and here's art today
a year later still trying to do the same
thing so uh this
is the minute right you know it's cute
pictures with frank so
so um i just love uh the social media
that
this sort of stuff when golf course
superintendents and people work on golf
courses or grounds crews
you know get their kids out there expose
them to their part of their lives
that matters to them a lot and and
exposing them to the natural world
and you know there's just there's just
something about working in this field
that uh allows us to share it with uh
many of our loved ones and and i just
love when we do that and so carl
with that i'm gonna pass it back to you
for another part of the show this year
where we're going to talk about this
very exciting research project we're
working on with partnership
uh uh with the new york state pollution
prevention institute
at the gallisano sustainability center
for sustainability
at rit and all of it's funded by the
department of environmental conservation
so why don't you take a minute and take
us through
tell me when you want me to shift the
slides hit next and i'll take care of it
for you
yeah uh thanks frank you know we're
really excited about this project
uh we call it an environmental results
program and the folks at rit are
very experienced at doing these sorts of
things
and essentially what it is is we're
going to try and figure out
what bmp adoption is like in our region
so we're kind of focusing on
western central new york uh as a region
for this specific
um program and what we're trying to do
is we're trying to figure out okay
what is bmp adoption like currently
and then can we change that can we do
outreach and education to shift that and
then we're going to go back in and
do some more random surveying and see
you know did it work
and a lot of this builds as you know
frank
on the bmps by the gcsaa the 50 by 2020
we've got all the
i believe all 50 states had codified
bmps
uh by this january i think it was
january 2021 that was a big
accomplishment uh you know really
exciting to
see uh excessive bmp resources for
everybody online
but you know as we know that's not
really the last step right the last step
is
getting everybody to do those best
management practices so
we spent last year with our folks at p2i
and also rick slattery a former
superintendent who is
extremely valuable to the project as a
practical mind right you and i
frank uh you know at a university you
know we don't necessarily have
um all the inner workings of her
superintendent figured out so rick has
been
super helpful in getting all that surfer
survey data last year looked at the data
and said okay we gotta
program some outreach and education
that's where we are now step two
so in the region we'll be doing a lot of
field days we'll be doing these webinars
little segments vmp tip of the day
that's what we'll be doing every week
but it's going to come from from this
poster so if everybody can see this
it's an info we call an infographic
poster we have some golf themes in there
right par
birdie eagle and these are all best
practices that we thought up
and we tried to categorize them of
course in categories water nutrient
management
pests and pollution and kind of things
that are cars
we'd like everybody you know in a
perfect world i think everybody could do
that pretty easily
birdies maybe cost a little bit more
money maybe some time maybe they're
harder to do
and then eagles is kind of something you
should strive towards
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
put this in the chat link everybody can
go you can go download this if you want
to print it out that's great
we're going to be sending this
physically to all the golf courses in
our little region central and western
new york as part of the project
but we're really excited about this
frank i know it's just kind of a pretty
picture but
creating awareness about best practices
is what this poster is all about
um so we hope you know in future webinar
episodes we'll be taking a little
part of this every week expanding it out
and making that a bmp to the
day so just wanted to share that project
we're doing regionally
with everybody here on webinar podcasts
and so and carl and and we'll be looking
forward to the
um the bmp tips each week uh
for a minute or two here uh in the
beginning
highlighting some of these things and
just you know again carl gloss is over
this a little bit but some of his uh
thinking as an engineer uh some of his
thinking as a golfer and also some of
his thinking not necessarily being
indoctrinated as a
a turf grass professional from his early
years like many of us
uh in this business you know he brought
to
everybody's attention you know best is
is is
is a reach for some people and sometimes
you know good maybe
we need a good better best approach to
do it and so
uh what we've done brilliantly with our
partners and with rick
uh you know as have sort of br tried to
make it look nice
look looked like something you'd put up
in your shop and start to create a
culture
around these sorts of things that are
really simple
basic stuff you know we didn't touch
everything with bmps we just
touched a few of them in this case just
to create a culture that
um ultimately is aligned with the
regulatory and the policy people moving
forward so
big thanks to carl and let me keep
moving on here and so last year
i'm going to go through a little bit of
the season last year and then
art's going to tell us a little bit
about what the winner was like i'll
probably bug him about
you know what we're anticipating after
the winner but certainly when we got
back to work
uh in the spring after the shutdown
everybody needed best practices just to
be safe
now looking at the weather uh in the
ranking ways that i like to do it
the early uh the entire season uh
the entire calendar year was among the
warmest
uh we've ever had in the history of
weather record keeping certainly uh top
five percent
and the rainfall as you can see in
general for us
looked normal but i think when you look
at that teal color
that cuts across new jersey our brother
from another mother rich
buckley uh told us he lived in a monsoon
uh
most of the year last year so we had
very distinct radiance and moisture last
year across the northeast
but what was pretty what got everybody
nervous i think when we shut down last
year was
that man spring was coming on like a
rampage
we were 20 days ahead of normal it was a
warmer winter last year
we were coming off a warmer winter
almost snowless winter honestly
and and everything was blooming and then
you know all of a sudden
uh you know yes golf no golf and then
all of a sudden
things shut down for much of the spring
uh we did not have good weather in april
and may the conditions pretty much
stayed there and stayed flat in the
early part of the season
were we going to play golf weren't we
going to play golf and when you look at
actual playing data from the national
golf foundation
and you look at the shutdown here uh in
the
in the game of golf and its impact on
rounds of golf
you see how dramatic it hit this
business but then
because we were one of the few things
you could continue to do
we've seen look at these year-over-year
increases here
between 20 and 32 year-over-year on a
month-by-month basis
and there doesn't appear to be any
dropping i'm actually
currently out in arizona visiting some
research out here and i can tell you the
parking lots are full to the brim
because golf
is one of the things that is able to be
done uh
relatively safely in the current
conditions and so
what's interesting is we have a weather
guy here um
we work with a golf economy group uh
pelucid and and stuart lindsay with ed
show consulting
these guys are business economists data
people
that try to figure out what the capacity
is to play golf through a golf course
and and um you know they look at
something like playable hours that
obviously is impacted by
day length but is also impacted by
temperature and moisture and
you know time of year that sort of thing
and they come up with these
playable hour measures and over the
course of the year
you know we didn't really have very good
weather
uh through much of the north for playing
golf at least by these playable hours
right so it didn't look like well the
weather was kind of normal
november looked good and if you played
golf in warm places january to march
was pretty good and and you know how
much you
actually utilize those times was more
important
right ra based on the number of rounds
you could put through
that were already reduced because you
had to space out t
times how much of that available tee
time space
did you use and you used a heck of a lot
more than you've ever used
in the past in fact everybody's
basically saying the pandemic did
what 15 years of grow the game of golf
things
couldn't do so the summer was warm
among the warmest ever in our region in
the northeast
it also brought continued rainfall
through jersey and into central new york
but you start to see some drought
starting to form here along new england
and then again
through the fall period again a very
warm fall
and a fairly dry fall dry to the point
where we had drought conditions uh being
indicated
uh by this map you had pretty severe
drought heading into the winter
art and of course the big story in the
winter
where all of our brothers and sisters
across the country
that were covered in snow uh for a
period of time
uh this is uh really unbelievable when
you consider
the landmass covered in snow here art
and i'll just wrap it up here
and and ask you to talk a little bit
about what the winter was like but i
came across this
slide of average days per year with an
inch of snow depth
and i see where we are where we're
between 75 to 100
and honestly our i was trying to find
out what the date of this map was
i can't remember the last time we had 75
days
of an inch snow coverage while i've been
living in upstate new york for the last
close to 30 years now and of course for
us with snowfall persistence
determines especially in the adirondacks
and the northern parts of the region
the longer the snow cover the more
you're going to get grey snow molds
which you see
in the background here a lot of gray
snow mold and and the wet
cool wet conditions that might persist
over the next few weeks
you'll see pink snow mold with the pink
around it so art i'll stop sharing and
and just ask you to talk a little bit if
about uh it may you
feel free to color in the lines with
what i just ranted about but
also if you want to talk to us about the
winner uh that's a great place to start
it's all yours pal
yeah why don't why don't we chat about
the winter a little bit frank and and i
have to admit after whatever it is 25
years uh i'm turning you into a
weatherman i really like to see it
and lots of good graphics you have i am
i am
a hundred percent rd guytano weather
protege i
i have uh yeah thanks for that um here
we go
and i know carl do you see the do you
see the results of the poll i was
interested in those
before i kind of went into my spiel i
wonder what people said
so yep there was um so basically
we had about 75 percent of people
thought it was about normal for the
winter
um and then the other 25 said it was
warmer than normal so no one said
colder than normal which is interesting
i love playing this game all the time i
look back at monthly data
i try and guess and i'm not i'm not too
often right so uh maybe that can frame
our conversation here
yeah i guess i shouldn't have doubted
you guys because i i figured folks were
going to say it was colder than normal
because of short-term memory and
february was colder than normal but
pretty much when we looked at the winter
it was definitely on the warm
side of normal i would call it an above
normal winter
wasn't you know frank likes his rankings
it really wasn't top 10 you had to
pretty much go to northern new england
like northern maine
to find something that had their top 10
warmest winter
in terms of precipitation i think
precipitation was kind of the main story
of the winter in in kind of two ways if
we look at like when we melt all the
snow how much liquid we actually got
um there january was very very very dry
and then kind of it was bracketed by by
wetter periods both in december
and and also this past month in in
uh february and really again um
that kind of bimodal you know what frank
kind of hit on it over the growing
season where new jersey was
really really wet and when you got north
of new york city they had dry conditions
particularly in new england
and that's starting to rear its ugly
head again i don't think i ever remember
folks in march starting to talk about
drought
but they definitely are in massachusetts
and connecticut we've just done some
drought calls with folks up there
and they're really concerned with
actually in that area a lack of snowpack
and the dry conditions over the winter
really starting groundwater hasn't
responded
um the streams that are flowing haven't
responded so they're really starting to
get their
their you know their alerts up for what
might happen coming into the spring
um i think snowfall was the big
uh ish you know if we wanted to go top
10 snowfall was the big one
and there again it really depended on
where you are you know there was kind of
a bullseye
of heavy snow from pretty much eastern
pennsylvania kind of skirted new york
city
got the the southern part of new england
and then back up into kind of our neck
of the woods
um you know binghamton had their
snowiest winter ever
on record in many places in that swath
from probably about allentown
pennsylvania
um you know up through maybe hartford
and connecticut were
were in in the top 10 in terms of
snowiest
and really that came in two big dumpings
or was that big before christmas dumping
that
um you know or around christmas dumping
and then and then one just this this
last month
um what else um frank i guess frank
you know frank touched on that snow
cover i agree frank that
seems uh pretty pretty high to me
for for up here having 75 days in the
winter that have
snow cover i mean you think about it
that's only that's almost two and a half
months
and yeah i don't remember that in in my
recollection of of being up here and
even
even this winter being a skier you know
and having lots of snow i don't think we
i don't think we came close to that i i
mean i'm i didn't look at the data for
that
but if i had to guess maybe i put it at
50 at best
and that would be for the far north as
well i mean how
different is i i think we got all walt
walt nelson on with us too and so
um you know how would walt be uh up
there is the persistence any better at
the higher elevations i think the ski
hills
have done fairly good this year haven't
they yeah i think the northern areas
didn't do that well in terms of snowfall
right they were the the tug hill and
things like that were below normal
actually
last i looked for the winter but you
know then again below normal from
for them still might be 150 inches of
snow
um they might have done pretty good in
terms of their persistence because they
did get it early on and then
and then um you know they're obviously
still have it now
so one of the things that comes up as we
you know to me
is the toughest part of of climate
change in general
and the weather we're seeing continue to
transition
is the transitions or are the
transitions
between the seasons uh you know the the
and
winter into spring i i honestly is the
biggest pain in the ass it has to do
with the startup of everything
and the way pests and growth and traffic
and everything gets going
um and i mean obviously it has
implications if you're in the fruit tree
business
you know the the the fall springs and
the implications of those kinds of
things
are we getting any smarter about
understanding
uh how the weather behaves in these
transitions or is the volatility
that we experi are going to experience
for the next couple of months
uh pretty pretty what we're going to
have to deal with
now with climate change yeah i think the
transition seasons are always going to
be
tough i mean this one gives us a you
know this current transition season
gives us a little bit to go
on um there are la nina conditions for
this winter and if there's any type of a
um any type of a relationship between
that and our weather
it tends to rear itself kind of at this
time of year
we typically see you know the cold
february was
a pretty classic signature of that
despite the temperatures we're seeing
right now i think the
longer range outlook for the rest of
march actually has it turning on the
colder side
again so i mean i think enjoy what we're
going to see the next couple of days
because
um you know it looks like at least the
looking out for the next couple of weeks
will be on the
on the colder side through march
that's this is well okay so i i i'll say
it's a bit the nightmare scenario
because of the following
one is golf is one of the few things you
can do we'll talk to our sports turf
brothers and sisters tomorrow about the
plowing off fields to play on them and
the implications of that
but this warm snap that we're having
uh is going to get everybody out itching
absolutely itching to skin it off i did
a webinar with the connecticut guys
today
and they're all itching to get out and
do it which means they're going to prep
the place
and then it's going to turn cold which
means the grass is not going to grow so
much
and it's going to have all those people
that want to get out there and start to
play
and what i want to talk to you about art
is soils and how
the frost went into the ground and is
slowly coming out of the ground and the
implications of that
in your experience for plant growth you
know one of the things i've always loved
about you is
you're actually a plant guy who decided
to study weather
and and turned out to be a data weather
guy
as much as a natural world person in
general so
what about how the frost goes in and
comes out of the ground and the
implications from your experience with
rooting anyway
yeah so i mean i think this winter is a
good example of i don't you know despite
you know february being cold and things
like that we had a heck of a snow pack
so i don't think this frost really got
into the soil
in in very many places at all this
winter so i think the soil
did not freeze very deeply at all this
winter
you know coming out of it now soils are
soils are wet
and as we move into this period of time
you know it's
even though they're not frozen i think
they're going to be you know they're
going to stay cool
for a while with them being wet in the
weather pattern i see coming up for the
next month
so um you know i i i don't
i don't see things uh happening very
quickly uh
through the next month in terms of
seeing things green up and things like
that the one exception might be in the
places that tended to be drier through
the winter so maybe kind of the boston
area
yeah eastern massachusetts and then as
you move down
maybe southern jersey into connecticut
where they did not get as much rain
uh this winter as other places so they
might warm up quicker and
and and you'll get you'll get activity
so
one of the things i talk a lot about uh
and i
you know obviously you're talking about
a situation where this might make sense
we have the ability to pigment the
surface
put dark sand on the surface uh do
things to
try to elevate surface temperatures to
get things growing and i've always been
interested
do you do you have any experience with
uh
darkening the surface uh you know look
and looking at how deep
that temperature will penetrate over
time we use covers a lot
are in in our in golf as well and and
you know you use it to trap the heat in
i always think trap the heat in
during the day but holding in uh at
night
and i'm wondering what your thoughts are
about if we get some sun
and it's cool temperatures but it's
sunny
if my surface is dark i'm wondering if i
can
boost the soil temperature a little bit
with that sort of strategy
yeah that's going to make the world a
difference frankie it really will i mean
anything you can do to darken that
increase the amount of solar radiation
from the sun
that's absorbed um you know you're gonna
you're gonna help it out quite a bit i
mean just you know all you have to do is
is you know it's the same principle
think of a driveway in a hot summer day
you don't want to be walking barefoot on
it and
and you know same thing as you go to
spring the sun's getting higher in the
sky
that's going to work quite nicely great
okay carl do we have any questions or do
you have a question from our
uh or for art otherwise i i have a
couple more i'm wondering if anybody
has any questions or what was the answer
to the poll
yeah yeah no questions um but the poll
is you know i think everybody got it
about right i'm surprised no one said
colder than normal i would have said
colder than normal again because of my
bias i'm just waiting to go out and play
golf i am cooped up and
i would have said colder than normal but
everybody else a little better
perspective there
no questions but frank i think maybe a
question for you you know
we talked about snow cover persistence
and how this year was a lot longer
than you know we have have seen in the
past
what are the repercussions from that uh
in our region
you know disease-wise uh i think snow
mold is what i'm trying to get at
you know what do you think we'll see
coming out here in the spring
so um i don't think there's you know art
i'm going to
pass i'm going to ask you first do you
look at snow length cover uh
do we have data that indicates snow
length cover
oh we definitely do um i'll have to
admit i don't know that off the top of
my head here for the
for for this but no no no that data
clearly exists
okay because because it's really it you
know anytime you get north of 30 days
you get into gray snowmobile territory
now
this is the interesting thing and it's
another thing for you art
you know snow isn't like utah snow
uh in the northeast it might be utah
snow for like a week
and then it melts and freezes and melts
and freezes and melts and freezes
um that's obviously not as good of an
insulation i wouldn't think
uh as a fluffy thing but do we
differentiate uh the snowpack as it
melts and freezes
um no there's no no distinction on that
it's basically a yes or no type thing
is there is there snow on the ground or
not and i guess i learned something
today i didn't know that magic 30 day
type number for
for snow mold um but but thinking back
on the winter and
and where the highest snowfall totals
were i would say that a good area pretty
much
north of central new jersey um saw
at least 30 days of snow cover this year
so
you know places in and around new jersey
uh might be those
ones where the snow cover was
particularly persistent i know i talked
to my
folks in new brunswick yesterday and
they said you know even though it was 70
they
still had snow on the snow on the ground
yeah okay so
so there is the answer to the question
carl whenever you get persistent snow
cover you probably get some grey
snowmobile now
as you go north to where paul coke does
the samples up in marquette
michigan and wisconsin way northern
wisconsin
uh and and you know i don't know if marv
sebum semen does them up in the
adirondacks
but certainly the you know the canadians
are
experts at this long snow cover means
uh gray snow mold that can take off some
of the leaf tissue and get itself
into the crown in general even with you
know 30 days you'll get a little bit
it'll probably grow
out of it but it'll take a little while
and i think art's point about how things
are going to be slow
moving forward is an indication of the
kind of recovery you're going to get
right now great uh pink snow mold again
if arts predictions hold true uh where
you get this cooler
i don't know wet or period art are we
going to be wet are we going to be dry
over there i don't see nothing yeah i
don't see much to indicate one way or
the other there in terms of
wetness or dryness coming up over the
next couple of weeks
okay so so whenever we get into
persistently cool weather carl
especially
especially we start you know goose in
the growth and getting it green and
getting it darker getting it moving it's
going to be more lush
and then you get those you know crappy
cool weather conditions and it's just a
bad situation for
things like pink snow mold so you know
there's a lot of things you can do and
oddly enough
to be honest take my non-chemical hat on
for a second
if you've got good sandy soils on your
greens uh
rolling will do a pretty good job on
pink snow mold
based on the stuff that clint maddox has
done out in the pacific northwest i
wouldn't have any reservations
if your soils aren't whack uh you got
sand greens that should be draining
as long as they're draining your home
free what you're gonna want to be
careful about
again especially what art's saying is is
if you're not getting the growth
yet uh you know your traffic uh you know
while i'm on this
call this is hysterical now i'm doing
this with you guys
a text comes across my computer it's the
cornell soccer coach asking if he can
use the playing fields tomorrow
so here we go i mean i don't think
there's gonna be a person in our
business
that isn't going to have issues with
people wanting to be outside on their
surfaces
and i for one am glad we have that
problem and art i for one am glad i've
had 20 years of talking to you to turn
me into a weather person
carl as we wrap up here at 8 30 i want
to pass it to you i'll thank art for
joining us all of you
for taking the time to be with us and
for those maybe listening
feel free to submit your questions
we'll take them and maybe tackle them a
little bit over the course of the
time we do this um and also helps us
inform
the things we're trying to do education
wise and stay tuned for more bmp stuff
all right carl it's all yours yup thanks
frank uh thanks art again
today for the problem thanks carl and
frank thanks for the invite
yep uh so for everyone we're gonna be
doing this every week uh rich i see a
question about some weed stuff
uh next week we got rich buckley on so
you know if you got any questions that
maybe don't fit into this week i'll
catalog those and
and maybe we'll address those with
future guests so um
you know for frank for art uh it's been
carl thanks for the cornell turf show
fastest 30 minutes in turk we hit it
right on the mail 10 30 a.m uh thanks
everybody for joining us we'll see you
next week
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu